[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome ed software's studio
director Tim Willits
[Applause]
welcome welcome
welcome to the 23rd annual quake on I've
been up on this stage many times now
every year and I use the same updated
version of the PowerPoint and I remember
when you all like lost your mind when I
switch the background from white to
black well this year is going to be
different and not only is it because we
have an all new look to our keynote but
because this is the biggest QuakeCon yet
we have more of everything more
attendees more people in the BYOC more
games to play more tournaments more
activities and panels so not only is
this the biggest quakecon it's the most
exciting one yet yes
so to start things off I like to say hi
to all my friends here in the audience
and everyone watching us live on Twitch
mixer YouTube and Facebook
[Music]
but before I give a quick overview I
want to take a moment to thank a whole
bunch of people the most important the
volunteers yes
every QuakeCon comes together thanks to
dozens of dedicated volunteers who pour
their hearts and souls into this event
they're here because they love quake on
this is family for them yeah they are
the ones that make this event so special
for all of us so one more time a round
of applause for the volunteers yes so if
you're having a good time this weekend
make sure you thank a volunteer and I
also want to take a moment to thank our
many sponsors and exhibitors who support
quakecon every year including everything
from balls to raiser and of course a
special shout out to my good friends at
Ventrilo they've been with us a long
time and once again they are bringing
their power up sweepstakes with the
prize pool of thirty thousand dollars so
as a reminder this is how it works you
can get one of 100 available tickets by
going to panels or competing and events
or sometimes you just make it lucky and
run into a QuakeCon volunteer or a
member of our Bethesda community team so
if you have one of the 100 tickets you
have a chance to win $10,000 in cash but
you need to be here Saturday night at
the block party to win so don't lose
your ticket and make sure you're here
yes and of course speaking of winning
we've got two major tournaments going on
this year as you all know quakecon is
the place where esports began over 20
years ago
and we're still going strong and we're
delivering the best in competitive
gaming right here so yes
so first we've got our Elder Scrolls
legends master series
so as we speak the final eight are
competing for the championship on the
eSports stage so be sure to check it out
when we're done here and for those of
you online know tune into twitch.tv
slash tes
for all the action and of course it
would not be quakecon without quake so
once again we are hosting a quake on
quake champions open 2018 tournament
which starts today with 2v2 matches with
a with a prize pool of a hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars and on
Saturday we've got my personal favorite
the 1v1 matches featuring
the players from the top eight teams
with a winner-takes-all $25,000 prize so
the action is spark is starting as we
speak so again online you can go to
twitch YouTube Facebook whatever add
slash quake and you'll be able to watch
all the action and for all of you you
can watch it downstairs at the expo hall
and our really very cool eSport stage
all weekend long so check it out
you know we have so much going on that
it's it's really too hard for me to
stand up here and talk about everything
I'm not going to talk about every panel
I'm not going to talk about everything
at the tabletop you know or about the
block party or this year's master
pancake theatre it's it's Mortal Kombat
which is going to be awesome yes so I
encourage you all to download the app
fan guru and look for quake on 2018 and
this is really the best place to to read
all the information that you need for
quake time and finally you know quake on
is more than just the amazing experience
the amazing games you know we also every
year try to find a way to give back to
the community and we've partnered with
nine local and national charities to
help raise funds and awareness so if if
you're here at QuakeCon please visit
these charities because almost every
charity has a special gift if you make a
donation like Dallas pets alive yes
these are so cute if um if you make a
donation to Dallas that's alive you can
receive one of these great Bethesda
t-shirts with our characters holding
puppies it's so cute or the American Red
Cross which once again is back hosting a
blood drive yes so if you if you need a
break you know from jibing your friends
and quake champions you should take a
moment go donate some real blood and
helps some real people in need and plus
like always we have a really cool gift
this year the Red Cross has a special
cooling towel so as you know Dallas is
really hot so this is a definitely
something that could help oh and for all
of you at home you know please visit
Bethesda dotnet where we have links to
all the charities in ways where you can
donate and participate so we've got a
lot more to come in this keynote you
know so don't go anywhere we have a few
things to mention concerning edge
software games we have a few bethesda
titles to talk about yeah but but right
now I want to turn over the stage to my
good friend Pete Hines
[Applause]
sup QuakeCon I like it I like it I like
the energy good to see all of you I'm
back from my 10th quake on back back
here at the Gaylord hopefully many of
you most of you saw our e3 showcase a
couple of months ago we showed off a
pretty pretty pretty big lineup it was
quite a show and not just because of
this moment actually that it was was the
t-shirt caps won the Stanley Cup
which I was clearly from Washington DC
but actually I'm just as excited about
the lineup that we have to show you guys
of new games and available games that we
showed off in the showcase we had more
games and we've ever shown before
including a number of it software titles
as Tim mentioned that you guys are gonna
get to see up here and just for a few
minutes and just for fun to recap some
of the stuff that we talked about the
showcase obviously we started off with
rage - Rage is back in an avalanche
working together we updated you on the
elder scrolls legends which as Tim said
the master Series is going on right now
and we are happy to announce today that
we have a new expansion coming called
Isles of madness which is going to
include cards themed around shared Gore
ass realm and we'll be talking a lot
more about that coming up yeah but a
bunch of new cards coming and obviously
we're super excited about getting a new
client out to you guys and bringing the
game to consoles so gonna be a great
year for legends and and definitely want
to watch the master series if you didn't
watch it yesterday some awesome matches
some awesome matches already this
morning and they're fighting today for
their share of that $50,000 prize pool
so stop by the eSports and watch it on
Twitch obviously we announced that that
doom game there's doom doom fans here
probably probably have a little bit more
to tell you about that here in a little
while crate champions as well which has
a manager tournament starting today as
Ted mentioned I I was in there with my
son yesterday in the BYOC and saw lots
of folks playing quake champions so
excited for the news we have to share
with you on that of course we ended the
showcase with a couple of big
announcements from Bethesda Game Studios
we revealed a loss Scrolls blades which
is a new and full-featured Elder Scrolls
game with console quality graphics
coming to mobile phones later this year
for free and if you have it yet you
should go to play blades comm and
register so you can be one of the first
folks to to play it when we release it
later this year and and then that fall
out 76 thing that they're doing a brand
new Fallout game entirely online where
every survivor that you come across as a
is another player is a real person and
let me remind you that as we said before
if you pre-order the game you go to
fallout comm to preorder everybody who
pre-orders will get into the entire beta
when it comes out this October you get
the chance to play the game before it
comes out in November and since we're
here in Dallas we have some interesting
news that's kind of applicable to Dallas
and to talk more about that news I want
to invite out Bethesda Game Studios Game
Director Todd Howard
[Applause]
thank you the wave oh thank you it has
been what we're taking questions
tomorrow there's a panel evidently
there's some fallout fans here I
understand you have questions and demand
answers there will be a fallout 76 panel
tomorrow where we will randomly answer
some of your questions give you a lot of
good information tomorrow
a-again great to be back here at
QuakeCon it has been many years I tell
you what the fans here in Texas meant
you guys are some of the best video game
fans in the entire world by far I was
reminded I and proved for that I did it
a demo for Skyrim years ago 2011 here
and a very long demo and in the
beginning of it a woman went into labor
and didn't leave so your love of games
and if you think about Texas and the
video game industry a lot of it things
that inspired us were created in Texas
take origin systems with Ultima a game
that inspired a lot of our work at
Bethesda created in Austin here in
Dallas doom a game you may have heard of
these are games that have not just
inspired myself but really set a lot of
what is great about video games
speaking of Austin we have a studio in
Austin working on fallout 76 and some of
you may know we have several Bethesda
Game Studios offices kind of around we
have the studio in Maryland we have the
one in Montreal Austin I mentioned and
I'm excited to say now in Dallas
and it's a great place for us to be we
have worked with the group in Dallas for
a while
escalation Studios they have done a
number of games with us from Skyrim VR
to follow VR to switch they are now
officially Bethesda Game Studios Dallas
[Applause]
and they've been working with us they're
doing key parts of Fallout 76 they're
working on blades and of our next big
single-player game star field and I want
to bring out when I have them give them
quick hello the studio directors at
Bethesda Game Studios Dallas Mark tardif
and Thomas Dane
[Music]
opera
quick story quakecon 2009 I was sitting
like that guy in the orange shirt over
here somewhere and that year was the
first year that we met Todd
fast forward nine years I'm standing up
here and our studio is becoming the next
Bethesda Game Studios studio how insane
is that like what I cannot I can't I
can't believe it I am we are all
extremely excited to be joining
officially Bethesda Game Studios I can't
thank Todd Howard enough thank you and
our amazing team in Dallas our Dallas
based team these guys I'm sure some of
our in here say hello if anybody's here
all right and we're really looking
forward to continuing to grow our studio
our a-class to do inside the Dallas if
code so it's gonna be an amazing thing
we've been working with these guys for
last couple years as Todd said and we've
got some really cool stuff we cannot
wait for you to see what's next
Thank You QuakeCon thank you
thank you thanks Todd Tim and Markin and
congrats again to everyone that at
escalation for becoming part of Bethesda
Game Studios as those guys continue to
kick some serious ass so now on to other
business
it would not be QuakeCon without sales
and the question is always like well
what's on sale and I prepared a slide
that nicely summarizes it everything if
we made it if we put it out if it put it
out if it's prey if it's an Elder
Scrolls thing if it's a fallout thing
whatever it's all on sale where is it on
sale it's on sale everywhere just
wherever you buy stuff just go and look
and it's on sale up to 75% off and over
the years I've just grown weary of
trying to list it off it's everywhere
and it's everything go find a sale
[Music]
and by the way if you would all just
cooperate and go by everything we've
ever made we wouldn't even need to do
this anymore you would just already own
it and I wouldn't have to tell you it's
on sale anymore and this includes by the
way all Scrolls online Somerset which is
on sale for the first time so ok next
I'm gonna turn it over to the guys from
quake champions but before I go quick
reminder about there is a Bethesda booth
over in the expo hall if you haven't
been over the yet you yoc or you're just
here to check out what's going on in
Bethesda we got a lot of stuff for you
to try we've got to VR games over there
so we have prey VR and the new
Wolfenstein cyber pilot VR over there
for you to try you can put your hands in
on and try prey moon crash and the new
Elder Scrolls blades run out on iphone
it's super awesome you gotta play it to
see for yourself how good it looks you
can test your shell skills in quake
champions and you can be one of the
first folks in the world to play rage 2
over in the booth so stop by and check
out everything we got going on and with
that I'm gonna turn it over to the
community team for quake champions
please welcome Andre and Joshua guys
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm Andre Carlos Oh fruit in the mic
does anybody like quake champions in
here right this is Andre Carlos and I'm
Joshua well we are the community
managers for quake champions you know
for fans like us it is a dream to be on
stage here at QuakeCon because this is
where it all began you know QuakeCon
isn't just celebration of bethesda games
it isn't just a celebration of eid games
it's celebration of all of you all of
our fans year after year who keeps the
fires of quake burning in your hearts
all those places this is also where
esports began and we're still going
strong with this year's quake on open
with two hundred thousand dollar prize
pool and these sweet trophies right here
[Music]
we have the best teams in the world
right here in Dallas just downstairs so
don't forget to watch on twitch.tv slash
quake or if you're here at QuakeCon we
expect to see all of your beautiful
faces in the East Sports Arena right we
just dropped in Arsenal new content this
month starting with this guy that
everyone will recognize from the first
quake game he is back he's got the sword
he's still throwing fireballs in the
arena it's tight
it really is tight
we've got improved matchmaking updated
BOTS I'm trying to get through the
finger can you see Matt yeah one blade
to blade we've got a new soundtrack and
soundtrack let's hear for the soundtrack
and if you play during QuakeCon you get
this awesome
exclusive QuakeCon 2018 heavy
machine-gun plus you get double daily
rewards all month long all right but
that is not even our biggest news
because right now quake champions is
fully free-to-play permanently
it happened we did it you know millions
of you have already experienced all the
speed all the frags all the fun in our
e3 limited freedom play trial and what
better place to bring even more of you
into our quake family than right here at
QuakeCon 2018 so right now you can get
the quake champions pack that unlocks
every champion now and in the future
future future future for less erudition
is on sale now at Gamestop if you're
here at QuakeCon check your swag bags
because you'll get a $20 off voucher to
get your very own giant scale bear
statue once again I want to thank the
best community in gaming for helping us
build and refine quake champions
[Music]
and now that our community is about to
get even bigger with even more players
joining us in the arena we love you guys
now let's take a look at our latest
trailer which shows just how quake is
evolved over the years delivering
everything you love about the game now
totally free
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
from the assets I will rise
[Music]
suffering is only the beginning
thanks Joshua and Andre and yep quake
champions is free and free for good so I
expect to see all of you guys fragging
the hell out of each other all QuakeCon
long [ __ ] yeah yeah good answer next up
I'd like to welcome game director Matt
fire and community manager Gina Bruno to
share the latest on the other Scrolls
online
[Music]
thank you thanks for the welcome we love
Dallas we love QuakeCon it's a rare
chance for us to talk directly to the
community so always great to be here in
Dallas so there's one thing the
community knows about ESO is that it's a
really really large game it keeps
getting bigger - that includes something
we announced back at e3 wolf hunter
which is our next DLC in wolf hunter
you're going to venture through to
werewolf themed dungeons including the
realm of the Daedric prince of the hunt
hircine himself and you'll also face a
terrifying werewolf lord and are vicious
minions now the good news is you don't
have to wait long because wolf unter is
available on PC and Mac this Monday
August 13th and on Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 August 28th and we're
really and we're really excited to have
the worldwide debut launch of the launch
trailer for / wolf hunter let's take a
look they will pursue you
is all they know
[Music]
they have your scent and nothing will
stand in their way
they fight on styling cloth Rowan shield
sword and spell
[Music]
and you think you would triumph against
them
[Music]
very well let the hunt begin
now wolf country's not all we have in
store for eso this year this fall we're
going to give you a deeper dive into the
argonians with Merck Meyer in fact it
was on this QuakeCon stage four years
ago that we showed our first concepts
for Merck Meyer we did end up exploring
other parts of Tamriel first but you
guys have been asking for a long time to
return to Black Marsh so with Merck
Meyer you get a new DLC sized zone to
explore a storyline that's as big as
last year's clockwork City DLC and a
whole bunch of independent quest dailies
and side objectives in Merck Meyer
you'll wade through the perilous bogs
and the Massey ruins of the Argonian
homeland to recover a powerful type of
Argonian relic but we're gonna leave it
up to you to discover exactly what it
does and how to use it and along the way
you're gonna get a really deep dive into
Argonian culture philosophy and religion
really what drives them and why are they
so weird you'll be able to answer these
questions and a lot more when Merck
Meyer launches later this fall so here's
a sneak peek at how the new environments
in Merck Meyer are coming along
[Music]
we'll be talking a lot more about Merck
Meyer in the coming weeks in the
meantime though for the first time the
zone of Vardhan fell from morrowind and
the ESO based game is currently
available as a free trial for a limited
time on all of our platforms so as
always we have a ton of other great
stuff that's coming with a Merc Meyer
update later this year but there's one I
want to highlight right now our optional
membership program ESO plus and I know a
lot of you are ESO plus members is going
to be updated in the fourth quarter to
be an even greater value for members
we're gonna add monthly loyalty rewards
and increase crowns per month so expect
here are a lot more specifics about this
in the coming months
and coming this September we're going to
have a new kind of in-game community
event one where the rewards for the
event will scale based on how many of
you participate we'll have a lot more
details on that in the next few weeks so
stay tuned so thanks for everyone
seriously the it's it's a great great
honor to come up here and talk to the
community we love coming here you're the
greatest community in gaming I know we
all say that but that's because it's
true we love you guys we have a ton of
amazing content that that's coming up
soon and later this year with with Wolf
Hunter and mark Meyer and but I look
forward to joining you all on the great
hunt next week and don't forget to stop
by and see us in the exhibit hall and
give us a try sorry on mic off that was
awkward
that was amateur hour that's my bad
that's on me thank you thank you thanks
again to Matt and Gina into all of our
ESO players don't forget to pick up wolf
putter on PC next week try the free
trial it's running on PC Mac and
consoles through August 15th and maybe
not we talked about some more it's tough
and to do that I'd like to welcome back
in software studio director Tim Willits
along with Avalanche Studios give
director magnets Ned first guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so when we first announced Rage 2 before
the e3 showcase we promised you
over-the-top action set in a massive
open world thanks to our friends at
Avalanche Studios
[Applause]
and of course we will add explosive aids
software style gunplay to the game yes
and you guys all loved the videos and
the announcements and we had such a
great response at our e3 showcase so at
the time and afterwards I was so
thrilled with the awards and positive
reviews we received at e3 thank you all
and this has been a great partnership
between our two studios and we're really
excited to show you even more rage to
today yeah we're on foot or in Vico
there is so much to do in this wasteland
so back at e3 we shared our first deep
dive into rage 2 featuring our seamless
open-world high-octane action well today
we're gonna show you even more we'll
take you to different locations deeper
into swampy wetlands and there are there
into authority territory and we'll show
you more factions like the goon squad
and the immortal shrouded and River hogs
yep and we will for the first time be
showing you a convoy take down where
it's only you and your ride facing a
whole array of hostile vehicles and of
course you will see more of our powerful
weapons including a assault rifle
shotgun and a rocket launcher
[Music]
[Applause]
and we also want to reveal a few more
more new tricks that you can pull off
with the wing stick so before we take
you back to the wastelands of Rage 2
just a quick reminder that the game is
playable here at the expo hall yes so so
if you want to be one of the first
people in the world to play rage to do
it here before the game releases in
spring of 2019 now let's show you even
more insane action that you'll be
experiencing in rage - thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the world of Rage to an
unprecedented partnership in gaming
bridge two fuses aid software's
best-in-class first-person shooter
mechanics with Avalanche Studios mastery
of open-world insanity this incredible
combination of action and fail plays as
a smooth and seamless experience
completely free of load screens set 30
years after the events of the first game
rage 2 takes place on an earth that's
begun to recover from a global
catastrophe life is returning to the
planet in the form of diverse and
awe-inspiring bio from jungles to
deserts to wetlands and more the world
is springing back to life your character
hails from Vineland a secluded Conclave
that you're forced to abandon after it's
attacked by the newly resurgent
Authority you start in the secreto
wetlands where you've been sent to find
dr. kvasir fans of the original may
remember him as your helpful ally in
true ed style your character comes
equipped with a sizeable arsenal of
powerful weapon
and making it struck over return a fan
favorite the win stick which has new
tricks in the game that will show off
for you in a bit let's talk with dr.
kvasir
he called 15 it was never deployed and
remains in orbit around the earth
I simply need you to travel to the Eden
Space Center and call it down from orbit
yes I forgot to say it might be overrun
by bandits the goon squad to be precise
the goon squad is just one of several
factions on counter and raged to hyper
violent and completely lawless the goon
squad leaves a trail of destruction in
their way The Immortal shrouded on the
other hand a group of elite bandits with
access to incredible tech leading to
mighty vehicles weapons and cloaking
ability you also have the river the
Abaddon mutant the authority and more to
contend with each faction has different
settlements combat styles and sweet
rides and to make sure to double down
there's a mind-blowing assortment of
charged up and chopped up and jacked-up
machinery to dry
you've got whiplash inducing bracers
that will leave your opponent's spitting
dust formidable roaming enemies and
wheels from every faction and says if
that wasn't enough there's also the
threat of massive convoys but they're
insanely powerful convoy leaders there's
so much more to find and ride
make sure you don't forget the hellfire
mortar
it's an all-purpose machine rolling room
oK you've arrived at the Eden spaceport
which is currently overrun with goon
squad but not for long because you've
got an entire arsenal of powerful
weapons gear and abilities to help you
deal with this threat
as you take down opponents your
overdrive eater will fill up when the
meter is full you can unleash overdrive
Display of power that pushes all of your
weapons past their limits and even
unlock special abilities for each one in
addition to your collection of
upgradeable weapons and gear there's the
new and improved wing stick created wing
sticks and target and kill enemies even
around corners
[Music]
unauthorized personnel are no longer
present threat has been nullified made
it to the control room now bring down
that EcoPOD
in consequence approved here you'll get
access to a brand new ability shatter a
fierce blast of kinetic energy time to
test out your new ability on
beware the massive mutant crusher you'll
come across many mutants like this
throughout the world of rage to better
stay on your toes or you'll get crushed
wide open world of Rage to is bursting
at the seams with weapons vehicles and
over-the-top action thank you for
quick look at what you can expect we'll
have even more insanity to show off in
the coming months
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright this time I have experienced
some great moments in the 10 years that
I have been coming to quake on the first
was in 2011 Todd mentioned the Skyrim
demo where the lady went into labor I
don't know if there's any pregnant women
here but a live birth today would really
push this demo over-the-top don't know I
don't ask for too much I'm not asking
that I'm just saying the second was in
2014 when we showed doom for the first
time to you guys behind closed doors
nobody got to see it just you guys and
honestly it was like a religious
experience to be there in person with
you guys getting to see doom for the
very first time now if you never worked
on a game before you have to know that
showing somebody your stuff for the very
first time can be a little nerve-racking
so I need you guys to let them know that
you're ready to see some doom eternal
well I'm feel I'm here
here to show us more their latest game
please welcome executive producer Marty
Stratton and creative director Hugo
Martin on Jupiter
thank you
[Applause]
thank you yeah you guys are unbelievable
it is awesome to be back here such a
thrill thank you all for joining us I
have to start by saying that we have an
unbelievable time so much fun with you
every year at QuakeCon but there is just
nothing like these years where we get
the opportunity to show you what our
team is working on it is the best thing
ever and we wouldn't want to debut doom
eternal anywhere but right here to you
at QuakeCon actually how many of you
were here in 2014 when we shared our
first look at the last doom yeah that's
awesome
well special thanks to you for joining
us again and for your continued support
also thanks to everyone watching on the
streams it's great to have you here with
us this year so let's get to it you
ready to rip and tear that's awesome
because literally that's where it all
starts for us killing badass demons with
big guns in unbelievable places
absolutely and as the doom Slayer you
want to feel Unleashed right like
nothing is holding you back to have a
pure unfiltered action FPS experience
and to do that we started with a very
simple goal make him the strongest and
most powerful hero we've ever created so
as you could see in these concept
illustrations he's at a bit of an update
a modification to his armor and some new
tools and abilities that make him even
more lethal of course nothing makes the
Slayer more lethal than his guns like
the ballista a gun that can spear demons
with an explosive bolt
or the Slayers own super shotgun right
yeah I love this it's like an Excalibur
and you'll notice there's a little thing
on the end there we call it the meat
hook and you're gonna love what you
could do with that thing it's it's
totally my new favorite but this is
what's great everybody has a different
favorite gun because each is a unique
and powerful tool for killing the
biggest and baddest demons you've ever
seen that's right because you know a
hero is only as strong as the enemies he
defeats so if you want to feel like a
badass
you got to wreak some amazing bad guys
along the way and do eternal has some
incredible enemies bit of as many as
last time these guys are insane yeah
we've updated some favorites reimagine
some classics from doom 2 like the
arachnid Tron pain elemental
and we got some new bad guys for you to
destroy - check out this arch enemy of
the Slayer and how about this guy the
Marauder
you know anybody noticed he kind of
looks like the Slayer
that's pretty cool is the story behind
that you know the coolest enemies
deserve the coolest deaths so we're
spending more time and energy than ever
before
making sure it feels absolutely amazing
every time you shoot punch kick slash or
otherwise rip and tear one of the demons
actually we've that we've created like a
whole system for this now and internally
we call it destructible demons you're
gonna get a CL out of that yeah alright
they know what's coming they always know
what's coming
yeah you ready all right
well you know what I know the answer to
the question but you ready to see him in
action let's rock
[Music]
please remain calm
you may notice a slight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
each other
we're actually that's awesome thank you
we're actually just just taking a very
very brief break we have we have a lot
more to a lot more gameplay from hell on
earth to show you actually but for this
next stuff we wanted to actually pick up
the pace just a little bit yeah how
about we go full bore and really see
what this lair can do maybe a little fov
change little mouse and keyboard you
guys like the mouse creepy bro all right
all right buckle up
earth is the melting pot of the universe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
all right thank you so glad you're
having fun so you probably noticed there
at the end that we're now giving players
the ability to take control of a demon
and invade another player's campaign
right you can actually even team up as
demons to form a slayer hunting party
yep it's all just a really fun new way
to add drama and unpredictability to
your campaign and this is just one of
the ways that will allow you to enjoy
doom eternal with your friends of course
it's up to you if you want to invade be
invaded or you just want to rip and tear
by yourself in your own campaign totally
up to you we're really excited about
invasion and you can look forward to a
lot more on this down the road
all right we've we spent a bit of time
so far just giving you a taste of Hell
on earth but that is just one of the
many many places you'll go
yeah we do a lot of environmental
storytelling in do maternal we get to
see how the UAC evolved journey into new
and fantastic places inhale and take you
to some places you've never been before
in a doom game wonder what that is we
love our little hint honestly we're
we're just huge Laura nerds at it and
everything we do has a story behind it
so if you like me and you like to
investigate everything we're gonna make
it worth your time it's really true
we're not just making a doom game
anymore we're building a Doom universe
you also know we're we're pretty big
tech heads at it and this it tech 7
engine allows us to display 10 times the
jitter and as you've seen all without
sacrificing a crazy fast experience
running at 60 frames per second all
right you know what we've actually got
another one of those cool locations we
just talked about you guys want to see a
little more gameplay all right you can
never say no to quake on so let's take a
look at what happens when the slayer
arrives on Phobos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you guys are unbelievable yeah
thank you so much really glad you liked
it that was awesome I you know I still
like watching it I know I know I was so
cool should play it it's great yes you
well that's right you know it honestly
it takes an entire team of dedicated and
talented developers to working hard
together to make what you just saw today
so it's truly an honor for us to be able
to come up here and represent the
amazing group of people that we get to
work with both at our offices in Dallas
and in Frankfurt Germany and because we
are lucky enough to be here at QuakeCon
we have many from our Dallas office here
in attendance so before we go we would
like to ask everybody from it to stand
up so you can see who they are and they
can feel some of the love
good work guys yeah amazing guys and
girls awesome thank you we love this
this was absolutely a blast you make it
awesome for us we'll see you around
one more time for Marty and Hugo and all
the folks at Inn
okay just to check did anybody actually
have their baby did I did I get my wish
I mean you came close even if you
weren't pregnant you probably came close
I know they showed a ton of news stuff
but there's a lot more to come with do
maternal before I wrap up once again I
want to give a nod and a thanks to all
of our QuakeCon volunteers who helped
make sure everybody gets in here makes
everything else happen please another
round of applause for those awesome
folks if you see them be sure to stop
them and say thanks you can also ask
them how to get involved as a volunteer
for an hour for a couple hours for a day
we would always look at more folks to
join the QuakeCon volunteer family for
those of you here with me there's
obviously a lot going on at QuakeCon so
I encourage you to download the app and
check out when all the tournaments are
happening all the panels and all of that
for those of you on the stream keep
checking bethesda net you can also
download the app so you can see when
everything is happening but that's it
for today thank you guys so much have an
awesome quake on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]